when classes start back up on wednesday
teachers and students will have a new
test to stay plan in place so it's for
students and employees who believe they
may have been exposed in school mary
jane bellissa joins us now live from
ccsd with more on this initiative mary
jane
yeah you know test to stay is a
voluntary program both school staff and
students have 24 hours within an
exposure to get a rapid antigen test now
the goal is to make sure schools stay
open safely in person within 24 hours of
exposure if students and staff test
negative with no symptoms they aren't
allowed to stay in school if they test
positive they will isolate at home while
students can opt in to learn virtually
tests are every other day for a week the
person can continue coming to school as
long as the tests are negative if they
don't take the test a person will have
to quarantine for five days vicki
kreidel a second grade teacher and the
president of national education
association of southern nevada is
worried the district does not have the
adequate staffing to keep the plan in
place and is concerned about
asymptomatic cases rapid tests are
notoriously inaccurate when you're
asymptomatic
that's
that's been said from a number of
epidemiologists
and infectious disease specialists so my
first concern is so i could have covid
and be accidentally spreading it
to my students and i see
43 students a day if an individual
misses one of the testing days they will
automatically go into an isolation
period ccsd says they have enough rapid
tests and more tests are on the way
now the test to stay program only
applies during in-school instruction
this does not apply to after school
activities like sports reporting live
here at ccsd mary jane ballesa live
local now